quelque chose
[Musique]
ce meilleur mois depuis toujours
c'était rien
et je vous en tête
[Musique]
vous avez été énormément avoir réagi à
ma vidéo réaction sur le trailer de star
wars 8 et mon dieu ce que vous avez
réclamé 1 3 théorie dessus et bien le
voici
beaucoup d'informations nous ont été
communiqués dans ce trailer et les
mystères se peaufine de plus en plus je
suis heureux de offert ce 3 théorie car
j'avoue que star wars 8 me hype et c'est
le film que j'ai le plus attendu dans
cette année 2010 est rêve
comment sont sans tarder voici les trois
théories que je vous propose
[Musique]
comme vous le savez nous ne savons rien
sur rai à part qu'elle possède un don
avec la force
néanmoins après avoir beaucoup réfléchi
plusieurs choses m'interpellent dans ce
trailer revêt semble posséder une
puissance incommensurable une énergie
brute si puissante qu'elle effraie luc
lui même suite luc nous fait part aussi
qu'il a déjà vu cette puissance et il a
malheureusement pas su la gérer
il parle bien évidemment de kay lorraine
aurait possèderait donc le même pouvoir
que kay lorraine un pouvoir très
puissant cependant contrairement à ray
kay lorraine est à skywalker tuchan
d'anakin et de l'udc coule dans ses
veines
le sens de l'élu sa force est tout à
fait justifiable sans compter sa
formation auprès de snacks et lui
qu'auparavant
ceci nous prouve quelque chose et nous
offre deux possibilités
la première est que red et sans
forcément de quelqu'un de connu dans
star wars quelqu'un de très puissant
dans la force
nous pouvons penser à anakin évidemment
mais beaucoup spéculent par rapport à
obi wan aussi et j'en passe bref
rennes veut pas sortir de nulle part et
posséder une telle puissance équivalente
accueil lorraine elle descend forcément
de quelqu'un de très puissant
cela nous aurions pu facilement dans ses
origines mais
une seconde possibilité existe aussi
tirerait ne descend donc de personnes
cela voudrait donc dire qu'elle est une
élue tout comme anakin lui même après
tout le côté obscur revient au pouvoir
et perturbe le monde qu'ali lorraine
semble être un dark vador numéro deux
est justement ray pourrait être une élue
créé par la force
possédant le même pouvoir que cai
lorraine pour justement pouvoir le
défaire leur bien contre le mal
à forces égales c'est tout de même très
étrange que ray semble posséder la même
puissance que cai lorraine ces deux cas
sont possibles et sont même certains le
trailer nous montre bien et apparaître
une véritable et lui aucun jedi dans les
films n'est sorti de nulle part sans
formation avec une force pareil à par
anakin quelque chose sommeille en moi et
s'est réveillée cette phrase que
prononcerait nous montre que ce pouvoir
de possiblement élus se réveille au
moment propice pour faire face à la
menace du monde soit le premier ordre et
tout particulièrement snj-cgt et key
lorraine de toute façon il est fort
probable que le 8 ressemble à l'opus 5
plusieurs scènes du trailer y ressemble
d'ailleurs et si c'est le cas attendez
vous à des révélations sur les origines
de ré après tout c'est dans ce sens que
nous avons appris que dark vador était
le père de luke
j'ai besoin que quelqu'un le dise oui ma
place tout ça le trailer jouant
énormément sur le rôle de ray et de ses
futurs choix
redouane encaissé ce nouveau pouvoir
qu'elle n'avait pas à sa connaissance
depuis le début sa vie a totalement
changé et ses responsabilités sont de
plus en plus importante
ray est perdu et ne sais pas où
s'orienter le trailer veut nous faire
croire qu'elle finira du côté obscur et
ce serait bien possible
néanmoins il faut se méfier de ce que
nous proposait trailer car ce n'est pas
du tout sûr que ray rejoint le côté
obscur mais ce serait fortement possible
bref revenant à la théorie ray et
désorienté il doit encaisser de
nombreuses responsabilités
elle est passée de vie misérables sur
jack ou un nouvel espoir de l'univers
maintenant en revenant au trailer
surtout sur les passages ou snow parle
écouté attentivement
quand je t'ai trouvée j'ai décidé en toi
une puissance brute est intenté et au
delà de ça
autre chose de tout à fait exceptionnel
il est temps
remplir
[Musique]
il est
nos parle tout d'abord de kayes lorraine
tout particulièrement de quand il l'a
trouvé et de la force qu'il détient
cependant quand nos poursuit il parle du
fait qu'il a trouvé autre chose de tout
à fait exceptionnel
et comme par hasard le plan pas sur rai
ce passage veut tout dire
il y a quelque chose à propos de ré
enfin à la fin du trailer nous revoyons
snow par les arrêts en lui disant
qu'elle doit accomplir son destin tout
en la manipulant via la force
ces deux passages sont réellement
étrange et montre que ray possède un
lien avec le côté obscur snoeck et kayes
lorraine dans le set snow qu'avait déjà
s'en tirerait via la force et le trailer
nous montre que ce dernier semble
connaître ray peut être via l'existence
d'une prophétie comme anakin avec dark
sidious je suis incapable de vous le
dire
cependant de nombreux mystères secret
via ceci est la fin du trailer nous
montrant cahill lorraine tendre la main
à rennes au perturbe encore plus tout
nous laisse croire que rêve à passer du
côté obscur et ce serait bien le cas
ensuite pour continuer dans tout ça ce
n'est qu'en parlant du destin de rennes
au informerait que ray serait donc une
élue mais une élue de quoi exactement
il se pourrait par exemple que reste une
élue d'une vieille prophétie du côté
obscur et snow chlorés décelé enfin
j'aimerais revenir sur les paroles de ce
noble du début du trailer
quand il énonce ses paroles nous voyons
cas et lorraine je sais pas pour vous
mais j'ai tout comme l'impression que
ray est un rapport avec cai lorraine et
que snow qu'il aurait décelé il parle du
fait qu'il a trouvé quelque chose de
tout à fait exceptionnel soit il parle
de calais lorraine
mais vu que le plan passe sur rennes
nous pouvons facilement penser que ray
et cas ils auraient non un rapport en
commun mais passons la dernière théorie
pour l'approfondir
je voulais parler de ceux ci à la fin
car si vous ne l'aviez pas remarqué mais
trois théories sont liés et vont de
façon crescendo après plusieurs
visionnages en détail du trailer
l'information clé que j'ai décelé et que
kay lorraine soit peine solo errerait
sont liés nous avons déjà eu plusieurs
indices de la théorie précédente
comme je disais ce ne semble connaître
le destin de ré et pourrait même la
considérer comme une élue cependant il a
déjà qu'à lorraine à ses côtés qui la
cour ont plu et il ne faut pas négliger
calais lorraine
ce dernier était qu'au début de sa
formation mais il est maintenant
beaucoup plus fort et d'après le trailer
qui l'aurait neyret posséderait le même
pouvoir
il semble être tous les deux des élus
des équivalents des rivaux ils ont un
lien
j'en suis sûr et certain beaucoup
avaient déjà décelé ce lien dans le set
nous voyons via les nombreux fans art et
caetera et lorraine fut disney en
premier car les plus âgés que ray et ce
serait maintenant au tour de red se
réveiller justement nous pouvons penser
au bien contre le mal
si rennes ne se tournent pas vers le
côté obscur mais elle pourrait très bien
se compléter et key lorraine comme le
ying et le yang
le titre des derniers jedi n'est pas là
pour rien lure pourrait certainement
mourir tandis que ray passerait du côté
obscur suite un son lien avec key
lorraine et je pense qu'il se
complèteront ensemble
en tout cas c'est ce que je ressens avec
ce trailer
et vous que pensez vous de ce trailer
que pensez vous voir dans star wars 8
dites le moi en commentaire j'espère que
cette petite vidéo vous aura plu et je
suis impatient de pouvoir enfin voir
star wars 8
la vidéo était compliqué à faire car
j'ai beaucoup déjà parlé de star wars 8
et je ne savais plus trop quoi dire
mais sachez que toutes ces théories ont
été imaginés par moi même donc merci à
ceux qui laisseront un pouce bleus qui
partageront la vidéo n'hésitez pas à me
suivre sur twitter pour les plus
acharnés d'entre vous c'était argot rock
et que le liner soit avec vous
[Musique]